สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะ
ขอต้อนรับทุกคนนะคะสู่ห้องเรียนภาษาไทย
ห้องเรียนค hens  Thai ค่ะแล้วก็เป็นการ
เรียนภาษาไทยเนี่ยแบบธรรมชาตินะคะเริ่ม
ต้นจากการฟังแล้วก็ฟังๆังเยอะๆค่ะนะวัน
นี้ครูปุ๊กกับครูชิก็มาพบกับนักเรียนทุก
คนนะคะในวันอะไรคะครูชิวันนี้วันอังคาร
ค่ะครูปุ๊กค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ 19 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะธันวาคมค่ะอ่าเดือนธันวาคม
เนี่ยเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะ 12 ค่ะปี
พุทธศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะ
2566 ปีคริศศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะ
2023 ค่ะค่ะวันนี้ครูปุ๊กกับครูชิมาพบ
กับทุกคนนะคะในวันอังคารวันที่ 19 เดือน
ธันวาคมปีพุทธศักราช
2566 ปีคริสตศักราช
2023 ค่ะค่ะแล้ววันนี้เรา 2 คนเนี่ยมี
เรื่องมาเล่าให้ฟังอีกแล้วค่ะ
อ่าครูชิไปทำเรื่องอะไรหร่ะคะไม่ค่ะเรามี
นิทานค่ะเรามีนิทานมาเล่าให้ฟังแต่วันนี้
เนี่ยเป็นนิทานแบบไทยๆเป็นนิทานที่เอาไว้
สอนเด็กให้เป็นคนดีค่ะออไม่ใช่แบบเงือก
น้อยเออวดิสนียนะไม่ใช่วันนี้ไม่ใช่แล้ว
ค่ะวันนี้เรื่องของเราเนี่ยเป็นเรื่องที่
นานมาแล้วนะคะที่หมู่บ้านแห่งหนึ่งค่ะ
หมู่บ้านก็มีบ้านบๆๆเยอะๆใช่มั้คะใช่ค่ะ
นะบ้านเนี่ย 1 หลัง 2 หลัง 3 หลัง 4 หลัง
5 หลัง 6 หลังเยอะๆค่ะหลายๆหลังก็เป็น
หมู่
บ้านแล้วหมู่บ้านนี้นะคะมีชื่อด้วยค่ะ
ชื่อว่าหมู่บ้านทองดีค่ะทองดีโอนี่ไงนะ
แสดงว่าเกรด A นะคะทององดี
99.99% องดีคนไทยชอบค่ะชอบทอง
อคือในหมู่บ้านของคนไทยนะก็จะมีชื่อชื่อ
เรียกเหมือนกันอันนี้ก็เป็นหมู่บ้านทองดี
ค่ะแล้วในหมู่บ้านก็มีเศรษฐีเป็นคนที่ปก
ครองเป็นผู้เป็นหัวหน้าค่ะที่ดูแลคนหมู่
บ้านนะซึ่งถ้าเป็นคนไทยเราก็จะเรียกว่า
เป็นผู้ใหญ่บ้านอย่างงี้ใช่มยครูจิอ่าก็
ตอนนี้ก็ต้องเรียกว่าผู้ใหญ่บ้านนะใช่นะ
เพราะว่ามีบ้านหลายๆหลังเนาะแล้วก็มีคน
อยู่เยอะๆก็ต้องมีคนที่เป็นหัวหน้าที่คอย
ดูแลนะช่วยเหลืออ่านะก็เป็นผู้ใหญ่บ้าน
เนอะแต่ถ้าเป็นสมัยก่อนอาจจะเรียกว่าอะไร
นะูชิสมัยก่อนก็ก็เป็นผู้ปกครองค่ะอื
อ่าผู้ปกครองก็จะมีผู้ปกครองดูแลหมู่บ้าน
ผู้ปกครองดูแลเมืองผู้ปกครองดูแลอาณาจักร
โอ้โหก็ค่อยๆใหญ่ไปเรื่อยๆใหญ่ขึ้นตอนนี้
ก็ยังมีหมู่บ้านตำบลอำเภอจังหวัดประเทศอื
อืออืนะก็จะเป็นลักษณะการปกครองแบบตอนนี้
นะนะแต่ว่านิทานที่ครูชิจะเล่าเนี่ยนะมัน
เป็นนิทานที่เกิดขึ้นเมื่อก่อนใช่มั้ยใช่
ค่ะในกลุ่มหมู่บ้านเนี่ยก็จะมีหัวหน้า
หมู่บ้านใช่มั้ยนะคะใช่แล้วหัวหน้าหมู่
บ้านคนเนี้ยชื่อว่าทองคำค่ะ
เอ้าหมู่บ้านทอง
ดีมีหัวหน้าชื่อว่าทองคำอทองคำเนี่ยเป็น
เศรษฐีค่ะอ๋อมิสเตอร์ทองคำเศรษฐีเหรอคะก็
แสดงว่าเขาต้องรวยมากๆมากๆๆๆๆๆใช่มั้ยถูก
ต้องค่ะมีที่ดินเยอะมีเงินเยอะนะคะก็เป็น
เศรษฐีค่ะ
อือ่ะแต่เศรษฐีทองคำเนี่ยนะคะร่ำรวยแต่ก็
การร่ำรวยไม่ใช่ร่ำรวยมาจากการ
คอร์รัปชั่นไม่ได้ร่ำรวยจากการที่ไปรีด
เอางเงินมาจากคนอื่น
อืเกี่ยวกับการพนันมั้ยไม่เค้าเป็นคนดี
ค่ะเศรษฐีทองคำเป็นคนดีนะคแล้วก็ไม่เอา
เปรียกคนอื่น
อืก็คือไม่ไม่ทำอะไรให้ตัวเองเนี่ยนะได้
มากกว่าคนอื่นนะแต่ว่าจะช่วยเหลือคนอื่น
ใช่มยนะต้องค่ะออเค้ามีเงินเยอะนะคะเคก็
ใช้เงินของเค้าอ่ะในการดูแลความเป็นอยู่
ของชาวบ้านให้อยู่ดีให้กินดีตลอดค่ะ
โออันนี้เป็นคนดีมากๆค่ะนะเอาเงินตัวเอง
เนี่ยอาจจะไปสร้างสะพานข้ามแม่น้ำใช่มย
เพื่อให้คนเนี่ยเดินทางใกล้ๆไม่ต้องไปไกล
แล้วก็อ้อมกลับมานะก็ใช้เงินตัวเองด้วย
โอโหถูกต้องค่ะเพราะว่าเค้าเป็นหัวหน้า
ที่ดีไงแต่
เอ่อหัวหน้าหมู่บ้านเนี้ยนะคะเศรษฐีทองคำ
เนี่ยค่ะภรรยาเนี่ยตายไปแล้วออก็มีลูกสาว
คนนึงใช่อ๋อก็มีลูกสาวใช่อือลูกสาวคนนึง
ค่ะชื่อว่าดอกแก้วอ๋อเป็นดอกไม้ชนิดนึงนะ
หอมๆดอกแก้วก็เป็นผู้หญิงสวยค่ะแน่นอนค่ะ
หนุ่มๆก็คือผู้ชายผู้ชายผู้ชายในหมู่บ้าน
เนี่ยต่างก็แบบชอบดอกแก้วรู้สึกรักดอก
แก้วอยากจะแต่งงานกับดอกแก้วเยอะค่ะแสดง
ว่าดอกแก้วเนี่ยก็โตแล้วใช่มั้ยคะูชิใช่่
ค่ะกำลังเป็นสาวเลยค่ะโอหเป็นสาวเอายุ
เท่าไหร่คะ 18
19 เดี๋ยวนี้เค้า 15 แล้วค่ะทำบัตรประชา
ชนเนี่ยถือว่าโตเป็นสาวแล้วโอ๊ยจะรีบเป็น
สาวไปไหนอ่ะเด็กๆเดี๋ยวนี้โตเร็ว
ค่ะก็คุณพ่อใช่มั้ยก็คือเศรษฐีทองคำเนี่ย
ค่ะก็มีลูกสาวคนเดียวไงตัวเองก็อายุมาก
ขึ้นมากขึ้นภรรยาก็ไม่มีแล้วก็คิดที่อยาก
จะให้ลูกสาวเนี่ยมีคู่ครองอืแต่งงานแฟน
แทนแแดนแทนแทนแแดนแต่งงานเอ้าก็เอ่อถ้า
เป็นคนเมื่อก่อนแน่นอนเลยว่าจะหาผู้ชาย
แล้วก็เอามาแล้วก็แต่งงานกับลูกใช่มั้ย
ใช่ค่ะก็ต้องเลือกผู้ชายที่เป็นคนดีค่ะอื
อเค้าเลือกยังไงอ่ะครูชิ
เค้าก็อาจจะดูว่าผู้ชายคนเนี้ยถ้าสมัย
ก่อนนะคะก็จะดูว่าผู้ชายคนเนี้ยขยันมั้ย
เป็นคนดีมั้ยไม่กินเหล้าไม่สูบบุหรี่ไม่
อะไรนะไม่ไปขโมยของคนอื่นอันนี้เป็นคนดี
ใช่มั้ยอ้าต้องขยันเนาะต้องทำงานทำงานทำ
งานไม่ใช่เอาแต่นอนนอนนอนนะขยันเนี่ยต้อง
ทำงานมากๆค่ะ
นะแล้วเป็นคดีคนเหมอันเนี้ยก็คิดว่าต้อง
หาเอ่อลูกเขยใช่มยอ่าเราก็จะมีแบบลูกสาว
พอหาคู่มาแล้วก็เป็นเราก็เรียกผู้ชายที่
แต่งงานกับลูกสาวว่าลูกเขยนะก็คิดจะหาลูก
เขยมาให้ลูกสาวเนี่ยนะคะทีเนี้ยก็ตัวเอง
เนี่ยก็เลยคิดว่าถ้ามีลูกเขยเนี่ยจะให้
ลูกเขยเนี่ยเอ่อเป็นหัวหน้าหมู่บ้านไป
ด้วยอยากจะฝากหมู่บ้านเนี่ยให้ลูกเขยดูแล
แล้วก็ฝากทรัพย์สินที่ตัวเองมีทั้งหมดเี่
ยกให้เพื่อดูแลลูกสาวแล้วก็ทรัพย์สินของ
ตัวเองแล้วก็หมู่บ้านไปด้วยเลยอ๋อทรัพย์
สินของเศรษฐีก็ต้องมีเงินมีบ้านมีรถมีที่
ดินมีทองมีอะไรอีกเนาะตอนนี้น่าจะเป็น
สต๊อกมาเก็ตค่ะหุ้นมีหุแต่เมื่อก่อนไม่มี
ค่ะอาจจะมีนะอาจจะเปิดเป็นโรงงานทำอะไร
เนาะทำน้ำตาล
ทำผักทำอะไรอย่างเงี้ยอาจจะแบบธุรกิจเนาะ
น่าก็มีเงินมีรายได้นะเป็นทรัพย์สิน
อ๋อเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเค้าก็เลยคิดว่าถ้า
เค้าเนี่ยแก่มากๆแล้วไม่รู้วันไหนเนี่ย
อาจจะตายลูกจะอยู่กับใครถ้าเกิดลูกแต่ง
งานกับคนไม่ดีนะก็เงินบ้านรถที่ดินทรัพย์
สินทั้งหมดเนี่ยก็เป็นของคนไม่ดีเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยต้องหาค่ะลูกเขยลูกเขยดีๆหา
ยังไงคะเค้าก็เลยเป่าประกาศค่ะนะคประกาศ
ไปทั่วเลยค่ะในหมู่บ้านนี้ก็ยังไม่พอนะคะ
ประกาศไปหมู่บ้านข้างๆค่ะประกาศไปทั่วนะ
คะหลายหมู่บ้านมากว่าไม่ว่าผู้ชายที่เป็น
หนุ่มเนี่ยเา้าบอกว่าต้องเป็นโสดใช่มั้ย
เป็นโสดก็คือยังไม่มีแฟนยังไม่มีเอ่อแต่ง
งานแต่งงานนะคะก็ถ้าเกิดเป็นผู้ชายที่ยัง
ไม่มีครอบครัวยังไม่มีแฟนเนี่ยนะคะและคน
นั้นเนี่ยเนี่ยไม่ว่าจะเป็นคนที่มีเงิน
หรือเป็นคนมีเงินหรือไม่มีเงินไม่สนใจนะ
ก็คือเป็นจะรวยนะเป็นเศรษฐีก็ได้นะจะเป็น
คนฐานะปานกลางก็ได้มีเงินพอกินพอใช้ก็ได้
หรือยากจนไม่มีเงินออก็ได้ก็ได้โอดีจัง
เลยหรือจะเป็นคนที่มีความรู้ดีนะะไอเรียน
หนังสือ
อ่าดอกเตอร์
อ่าหรืออาจจะไม่ได้เรียนหนังสือเลยแต่
เป็นคนทำงานเก่งรู้จักการทำงานก็ได้หมด
อืมีความรู้ไม่มีความรู้มีไม่เป็นไรนะคะ
ขออย่างเดียวให้เป็นคนดีดูแลครอบครัวได้
ดูแลทรัพย์สินได้ดูแลหมู่บ้านได้อืเศรษฐี
ก็บอกพอแล้วแค่นี้ใช่เพราะว่าท่านเศรษฐี
ทองคำเนี่ยเขาก็มีเงินเยอะอยู่แล้วเนาะมี
บ้านมีรถมีที่ดินเยอะอยู่แล้วเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยเขาก็ไม่ถ้าเกิดเขาตายเนี่ยเขาก็
ต้องให้ลูกสาวลูกสาวก็ต้องอยู่กับลูกเขย
ใช่มั้ยก็เท่ากับลูกเขยก็ต้องมีเงินอยู่
แล้วไงอือืถูกต้องพอรู้แบบนั้นเนี่ย
เศรษฐีก็เลยให้คนเนี่ยไปเป่าประกาศนะว่า
อือเค้าก็จะใช้วิธีตะโกนเสียงดังๆใช่มั้ย
แล้วก็อาจจะมีตึงึงๆเจ้าค้า
เอ้ยนะท่านเศรษฐีทองคำอยากหาลูกเขยนะใคร
ที่เป็นโสดไม่ได้แต่งงานไม่มีแฟนให้ไป
เลือกคู่ในอีก 3 วันข้างหน้า
อ่าถ้าคนไหนเนี่ยเอ่อคุณหนูดอกแก้วก็คือ
ลูกสาวเนี่ยเป็นคนเลือกผู้นั้นก็จะได้
ทรัพย์สมบัติก็คือได้เงินได้ทองได้ทุก
อย่างที่เศรษฐีมีแล้วก็ยังได้ตำแหน่งหัว
หน้าหมู่บ้านด้วย
อโอนะแต่ว่าคือต้องเป็นคนดีอแล้วก็ชอบที่
จะดูแลคนอื่น
เออทีนี้ผู้ชายที่ได้ยินได้ยินการประกาศ
ใช่มยก็รู้สึกแบบอูยตื่นเต้นเราจะไปให้
เขาเลือกตั้งไม่ใช่เลือกคู่ไม่ได้โหวต
นายกค่ะอ้าก็เป็นหัวหน้าหมู่บ้านไงเอ้า
แต่ว่าเคตั้งใจให้ไปแต่งงานกับลูกสาวอ๋อ
ไปเลือกคู่เพราะว่าลูกสาวจะต้องต้องมีคู่
ค่ะนะถ้าคนเดียวเนี่ยไม่เป็นคู่นะต้อง
เป็น 2 คนถึงจะเรียกว่าเป็นคู่คูู่่ๆเอาา
คู่เดียวนะอ่าอันนี้อครูปุ๊กครูชิเนี่ย
ไม่ได้เป็นคู่ใช่มั้ยไม่ได้ค่ะคู่กันต้อง
มีผู้หญิงผู้ชายออนะแต่แต่เดี๋ยวนี้อาจจะ
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงได้ผู้ชายผู้ชายได้แต่สมัย
ก่อนนะไม่ได้จะหาคู่ให้กับลูกสาวก็ต้องไป
ไปประกาศหาผู้ชายค่ะเรียกผู้ชายมาเนาะก็
จะได้มีผู้ชายมาให้ลูกเนี่ยเลือกเยอะๆค่ะ
แล้วก็ท่านเศรษฐีทองคำเนี่ยก็จะเป็นคน
เลือกก่อนใช่มั้ยใช่ก็ต้องเช็คก่อนค่ะอ่า
อันดับที่ 1 เลยด่านที่ 1 ก็ต้องผ่านท่าน
เศรษฐีทองคำก่อนเลือกมาก่อนแล้วก็ลูกสาว
ค่อยเลือกอีกทีนึงอ่าแต่ก็เลือกได้คน
เดียวนะใช่ค่ะผู้ชายมีกี่กี่รคนก็ตามนะ
แต่คนที่จะแต่งงานก็มีแค่คนเดียวนะถูก
ต้องเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยพ่อก็ต้องชอบลูกก็
ต้องชอบ
อือทีนี้ก็มีผู้ชายคนหนึ่งค่ะชื่อว่า
ขนุนเป็นหนุ่มที่ไม่มีเงินค่ะยากจน
ออขนุนเนี่ยนะมิสเตอร์ขนุนน่ะเหรอใช่นะคะ
เป็นคนที่ไม่รวยแต่เป็นคนดีนะคะเป็นคนดี
ชอบช่วยเหลือคนอื่นแล้วก็ขยันทำงานเพราะ
ว่าเค้าก็จะไปรับจ้างทำงานไปถามคนนู้นคน
นี้มีงานอะไรให้ทำนะคนให้ทำงานเนาะอาจจะ
ไปตัดไม้ตัดทำฟืนทำอะไรแบบเนี้ยก็ให้เงิน
ขนุนมิสเตอร์ขนุนก็เลยมีเงินสำหรับไปซื้อ
ซื้อข้าวกินนะก็ขยันทำงานทุกวันเนี่ยออก
ไปทำงานทำงานทำงานแล้ว 1 วันก็ทำงานเยอะๆ
แต่ว่ามันเป็นงานที่ไม่ได้เงินเยอะๆเนาะ
อืเขาก็เลยยังจนอยู่ค่ะใช่ค่ะแต่ขนุน
เนี่ยเคยเห็นหน้าเอ่อแม่ดอกแก้วแล้วกอ
เห็นหน้าครั้งแรกก็รู้สึกหลงรัก
โอ้โหเา้าเรียกว่ารักแรกพบเออรักแรกพบ
เพราะว่าพบกันก็คือเจอกันเนี่ยครั้งแรก
เลยครั้งที่ 1 เนาะก็รักเลยไม่รู้ทำไมรัก
เลยเหมือนๆเดินๆเดินไปแล้วก็ตกหลุมรักอ๋อ
หลุมที่เขาขุดเอาไว้สำหรับความรักเหรอ
คะเดินไปสะดุดแล้วก็ตกหลุมรักผู้หญิงคน
นี้นะคะก็รู้สึกแบบปักใจมากแต่ตัวเองก็
รู้ไงว่าตัวเองเนี่ยยากจนไม่มีเงินแต่ผู้
หญิงที่ตัวเองชอบนั้นน่ะเป็นลูกเศรษฐีทอง
คำรวยใช่มั้ยใช่ก็เลยแบบว่าไม่เคยไปจีบนะ
ก็แค่แอบดูแล้วก็รู้สึกหลงรักแต่พอได้ยิน
ประกาศอ่ะของเศรษฐีทองคำอ่ะว่าผู้ชายคน
ไหนที่เป็นคนดีใช่มั้ยไม่ว่าจะยากจนจะ
เอ่อรวยจะไม่มีความรู้มีความรู้ใครก็ได้
นะขอให้เป็นโสดใช่แล้วก็อีก 3 วันใช่มั้ย
ครูชิวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะวันพุธพฤหัสบดี
ศุกร์อ๋อวันศุกร์ค่ะวันศุขเป็นวันดีค่ะ
เหมาะที่จะหาคู่จะได้มีความสุขอืมอืเลือก
คู่ในวันศุกร์ก็มีความสุขใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะพอ
ผู้ชายมาพร้อมกันแล้วเนี่ยขนุนเองก็มาแต่
เช้าเหมือนกันค่ะก็เจอผู้คนโอ้โหผู้ชาย
มากหน้าหลายตาเยอะแยะไปหมดเลยนะคะมีทั้ง
คนรวยนะคะคนไอคดีคนที่ทำงานเป็นทหารมี
โอ้โหมีครอบครัวที่แบบมีตำแหน่งก็มาเต็ม
ไปหมดเลยค่ะครูปุ
ออก็ดีสิคะมีให้เลือกเยอะๆใช่นะแล้วจะ
เลือกยังไงล่ะคะก็มีเอ่อท่านเศรษฐีก็มีคำ
ถามค่ะคำถามให้กับผู้ชายทุกคนว่าถ้าทุกคน
เนี่ยนะคะเป็นได้เป็นหัวหน้าหมู่บ้าน
นะถ้าแต่ละคนเนี่ยได้เป็นผู้นำหมู่บ้าน
นี้
เนี่ยจะตัวตัวผู้ชายทุกคนเนี่ยมีความดี
อะไรที่จะทำให้หมู่บ้านเนี้ยดีต่อๆไปอืเอ
โอหคิดเรื่องหมู่บ้านดูแลคนอื่นมากกว่า
ลูกสาวอีกนะอ่าอ้าเพราะว่าถ้าเกิดดูแล
หมู่บ้านได้ดีก็แสดงว่าต้องดูแลลูกสาวได้
ดีนะสามารถทำดูแลสิ่งที่ใหญ่ได้เพราะ
ฉะนั้นดูแลสิ่งที่เล็กๆก็ไม่มีปัญหาแน่อื
อืนะแล้วเป็นยังไงคะผู้ชายที่มาเนี่ยมี
ใครตอบมั้ยคะว่าจะทำอะไรมีค่ะผู้ชายคนแรก
ค่ะเป็นลูกเศรษฐีเป็นชายอ้วนคนนึงนะคะ
อยู่หมู่บ้านใกล้ๆเนี่มาถึงก็บอกเลยว่า
ข้าพเจ้าเนี่ยเป็นลูกเศรษฐีนะคะมีเงินมี
ทองมากมายข้าพเจ้าจะใช้เงินใช้ทองที่
ข้าพเจ้ามีอยู่เนี่ยแจกจ่ายให้กับชาวบ้าน
เนี่ยชาวบ้านจะได้อยู่ดีกินดี
โอ้โหจริงหรือเปล่าพอใช้เงินหมดแล้ว
เนี่ยชาวบ้านก็จะต้องไม่มีเงินอีกน่ะสิ
ครูชิคิดว่าเอ่อลูกเศรษฐีคนนี้กะจะแจก
เงินอย่างเดียวค่ะนะคะมีแต่วิธีการแจก
เงินให้ทุกคนมีกินมีใช้นะคนที่ 2 ก็มาเลย
ครับเป็นลูกของน่าจะเป็นนักรบทหารอ่าเป็น
ทหารเป็นนักรบมีมิตรดาบแล้วก็บอกข้าเนี่ย
มีฝีมือในด้านดาบข้าจะใช้เพลงดาบของข้า
เนี่ยมีดดาบของข้าเนี่ยปกป้องชาวบ้านใน
หมู่บ้านแห่งนี้อ่า
อืถ้าใครเข้ามาในหมู่บ้านแล้วก็ทำให้คนใน
หมู่บ้านเดือดร้อนข้าก็จะเอามีดดาบของข้า
เนี่ยเข้าไปปกป้องอ่าอเหมือนจะเป็นตำรวจเ
ใช้ปืนแล้วไม่ใช่เหรอคะกูชิเ้าสมัยก่อน
ยังไม่มีปืนไงอ๋อมี
มีดเหมือนซามูไรใช่มั้ยมีดด่าใช่อ่าอัน
นี้ก็จะเป็นแบบนักรบใช่มั้ยเป็นทหารนักรบ
แต่ก็มีคนที่เป็นเหมือนกับวิศวกรนะเป็นคน
ที่สร้างบ้านสร้างเทคโนโลยีต่างๆให้เจริญ
ก้าวหน้าเนี่ยก็ออกมาเลยข้าเนี่ยมีไอคิว
ดีเป็นวิศวกรที่เก่งมากข้าจะสร้างหมู่
บ้านนี้ให้เป็นหมู่บ้านที่สวยงามที่สุด
แล้วก็จะมีอุปกรณ์ต่างๆทำให้ทุกคนสะดวก
สบาย
ออ
แสดงว่าจากเมื่อก่อนต้องไปตักน้ำใช่มยที่
แม่น้ำนะเอามาใช้เนี่ยอาจจะแบบมีท่อใช่มย
มีท่อแล้วก็เปิดจากที่บ้านนะเหมือนตอนนี้
เนแล้วก็เปิดน้ำออกมาอันนี้ก็ทำให้เรา
สะดวกแล้วก็สบายมากขึ้นเนาะสะดวกก็คือ
เปิดก็ใช้ได้เลยไม่ต้องเดินไปไกลแล้วก็
แบกมาหนักนะอ่าเห็นมอันนี้ก็ผู้ชายคนนึง
ก็นเตัวเองขึ้นมาผู้ชายอีกคนค่ะเป็นหมอ
เอ้าคุณหมอก็ไอคิวดีสิค่ะใช่ค่ะก็บอกเลย
ข้าเป็นมีความรู้ทางด้าน
หมอรักษาผู้คนที่เจ็บป่วยเนี่ยให้แข็งแรง
มีสุขภาพแข็งแรงเยอะแยะแล้วก็ไม่ตายมา
เยอะแล้วถ้าข้าไม่เป็นเจ้าเมืองที่หมู่
บ้านทองดีเนี่ยข้าจะใช้ความรู้รู้ด้าน
เป็นหมอของข้าเนี่ยดูแลรักษาคนเจ็บป่วยนะ
คะโควิด- 199 จะไม่มีโอเมื่อก่อนยังไม่มี
ค่ะอ๋อยังยังไม่มีโควิดผู้คนในหมู่บ้านจะ
เป็นมีสุขภาพแข็งแรงค่ะไม่มีโรคไม่มี
อันตรายใดๆทั้งสิ้นโอ้ก็ดีนะโอหแสดงว่า
ท่านเศรษฐีเนี่ยจะต้องคิดเยอะเลยโอ้โหอัน
นี้ก็ดีเนาะสร้างบ้านก็ดีนะเป็นคุณหมอก็
ดีเออเป็นคนรวยก็ดีโอเป็นโอ้โหนักรบก็ดี
อ้าแล้วจะเลือกยังไงเนี่ยครูชิ
อ้าวแต่ละคนก็เสนอตัวเองนะบางคนก็เป็นครู
ก็จะสอนวิชาความรู้ให้คนอื่นมีความรู้บาง
คนก็เป็นเอ่อคนปลูกต้นไม้เก่งก็จะสอนให้
คนเนี่ยปลูกต้นไม้มีรายได้
จนกระทั่งเนี่ยทุกคนก็เสนอหมดแล้วคนสุด
ท้ายก็คงเป็นขนุนของเราค่ะอขนุนผู้ที่ไม่
มีเงินไม่มีอำนาจไม่มีความรู้คือความรู้
ในที่นี้หมายถึงเรียนหนังสือเนาะไม่ได้
เรียนหนังสือนะฮคือไม่มีเงินไปเรียน
หนังสือแต่มี
ไอค
นะอือฮึก็ได้พูดกับก็คนสุดท้ายแล้วใช่มย
ก็เสนอตัวเป็นคนสุดท้ายให้ทุกคนเสนอตัวไป
ก่อนจนหมดแล้วเนี่ยขนุนก็กล่าวเป็นคนสุด
ท้ายว่าคาน้อยเนี่ยไม่มีอะไรดีเด่นไปกว่า
คนอื่นนะ
นะก็ไม่ไม่มีเงินเหมือนๆคนอื่นที่จะเอา
เงินเนี่ยมาแจกให้เอ่อคนทั่วๆไปไม่สามารถ
ที่จะสร้างบ้านบ้านไม่สามารถที่จะรักษา
ผู้ป่วยนะคะคาน้อยเนี่ยมีแต่ความดี
นะยึดมั่นอยู่กับความดีนะคะแล้วก็จะใช้
ความดีเนี่ยค่ะนะที่มีอยู่ในตัวเองเนี่ย
นะจะดูแลความทุกข์ความเดือดร้อนของชาว
บ้านด้วยความเมตตาของตัวเองอืเมตตาก็คือ
พร้อมที่จะช่วยเหลือคนอื่นเนาะอยากให้
เค้าอ่ะคนที่มีปัญหาก็จะได้ช่วยไปก็หมด
ปัญหาหรือมากๆก็ลดลงน้อยลงนะช่วยแก้ปัญหา
ให้อะไรแบบนี้นะโอ้โหนะแต่พอขนุนพูดเนี่ย
ทุกคนก็หัวเราะโอ
ขนุนไม่มีเงินไม่มีความรู้ไม่มีอะไรเลย
ไม่เจรียมตัวเลยนะอ่าเจียมตัวก็ต้องรู้สิ
ว่าตัวเองเนี่ยไม่เหมาะสมนะดอกแก้วเนี่ย
เขารวยเขาสวยนะตัวเองเนี่ยไม่มีอะไรเลย
ความรู้ก็ไม่มีต้องอยู่กับคนที่ไม่มีความ
รู้สิเจรียมเนื้อเจรียมตัวเบอกงี้อ่าให้
คิดซิว่าดอกแก้วเอยู่สูงเธอน่ะมันอยู่ต่ำ
อ่าต่ำต้อยเหลือเกินต่ำมาก
นะคะโอก็ดูคนดูถูกบูลี่นะ
เนี่ยคนก็ดูถูกขนุนหมดเลยนะแต่ในขณะที่
กำลังพูดคุยกันอยู่นั้นก็มีชาวบ้านค่ะ
วิ่งมาเลยเกิดเรื่องใหญ่แล้วท่านท่าน
เศรษฐีเกิดเรื่องใหญ่แล้วท่านเรื่องอะไร
อืก็ท่อระบายน้ำเสียในหมู่บ้านเราสิมัน
อุดตันมันไม่ไหลตอนเมันตันไปหมดเลยตอน
เนี่ยน้ำเน่าเสียส่งกิ่นเหม็นไปทั่วหมู่
บ้านแล้ว
โอนะมันน่ะถ้าเป็นตอนนี้นะนักเรียนน่าจะ
มีพลาสติกนะมีเศษขยะไปอุดตันเพราะว่าท่อ
ระบายน้ำหมายถึงท่อเวลาเราใช้น้ำน้ำจะออก
ไปเนี่ยนะมันก็ต้องผ่านท่อระบายน้ำหรือ
ว่าฝนตกนะนมันก็จะไหลลงไปในแม่น้ำนะลำ
คลองแต่อันเนี้ยมันไปอุดตันตันเลยน้ำก็
ไม่ไหลพอน้ำไม่ไหลมันก็เกิดกลิ่นเน่า
เหม็นเพราะมันอาจจะมีพวกสัตว์ที่ตายเนาะ
หรือว่าต้นไม้อะไรที่มันตายแล้วนานๆมันก็
จะเน่าอาจจะมีหนอนวบๆๆหรืออาหารที่คนทิ้ง
ไปในท่อระบายน้ำเห็นมยใช่อาหารที่แบบทุก
คนล้างจานก็อาจจะทิ้งในท่อระบายน้ำไม่ดี
ใช่มยแต่ตอนนี้เนี่ยมันส่งกลิ่นเหม็นแสดง
แงว่ามันเหม็นมานานแล้วเหมือนกันนะอืพวก
ตัวนี้มันเหม็นมากเลยครับเศรษฐีก็เลยใช้
เหตุการณ์นี้เลยเศรษฐีทองคำก็บอกเอาล่ะ
ตอนเหมู่บ้านเราเนี่ยมีปัญหานะคะมีสิ่ง
อุดตันอยู่ที่ท่อระบายน้ำขออาสาสมัครใน
บรรดาหนุ่มๆที่มาเป็นลูกเขยข้าเนี่ยใคร
บ้างที่จะแก้ปัญหานี้ได้อ๋อถ้าอาสาก็จะ
ต้องยกมือแล้วก็ผมครับผมครับผมจะไปครับ
อันนี้ใช่มั้ยแต่หมอ
ก็เสร็จ
ทีทุกคนก็แบบเอ้ยเอ่องานนี้ผมไม่ค่อยถนัด
ครับเออน่าจะเอ่อลองถามคุณหมอคุณหมออาจจะ
เก่งคุณหมอโอ๊ยผมก็ได้แต่รักษาคนครับไอ้
เรื่องไปลงไปน้ำเน่าแล้วไปขุดท่อผมก็ไม่
เป็นเหมือนกันครับนะคะงคนหนุนก็ยกมือขึ้น
มาเลยค่ะอาสาเลยเห็นมแต่ละคนเนี่ยไม่มี
ใครอาสาเลยแต่ขนุนผู้ต่ำต้อยเนี่ยล่ะค่ะ
บอกว่าผมอาสานะคผมเนี่ยเกิดอยู่กับดินกับ
ขี้ดินขี้ขี้หมาขี้แมวขี้วัวมันสกปรกอยู่
แล้วนะผมไม่กลัวเรื่องสกปรกครับแต่จะช่วย
ชาวบ้านได้ใช่เพราะว่าสกปรกแบบเนี้ยอาบ
น้ำหูสบู่ก็หายนะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยผมอาสา
ที่จะไปทำเองนะแล้วขนุนก็ไปทำเนาะ
มิสเตอร์ขนุนก็ไปทำนะขุดท่อระบายน้ำท่าน
เศรษฐีก็บอกมันเหม็นนะบอกไม่เป็นไรครับผม
ทำเองก็ทำๆๆนะจนเสร็จอืโอ้ขนุนไม่รู้สึก
ว่าจะต้องอายเลยถ้าเกิดแบบว่าไปช่วยแล้ว
ก็ไปทำแบบนี้นะคนจะบอกเอ้ยไอ้สกปรกอะไร
อย่างเงี้ยรู้สึกไม่กลัวเลยก็เลยเป็นที่
ประทับใจของดอกแก้ว
อืเศรษฐีทองเอ่อเศรษฐีทองคำก็ชอบนะคโอ้โห
เห็นปัญหาปุ๊บกระโดดเข้าไปแก้ปัญหาเลยให้
กับชาวบ้านอย่างงี้สิเหมาะที่จะเป็นเอ่อ
เจ้าเมืองนะดูแลปกครองหมู่บ้านแห่งนี้นะ
ฮะออย่างน้อยคนอื่นทำไม่ได้เทำได้ไง
นะดอกแก้วก็เลยเอาพวงมาลัยค่ะเพราะว่าดอก
แก้วเป็นคนเลือกคนสุดท้ายใช่มย
อ่าเศรษฐีก็โหวตให้ขนุนนะดอกแก้วก็เอาพวง
มาลัยมาเลือกขนุนเช่นเดียวกันขนุนก็ตกใจ
นะเออๆให้ให้ผิดคนหรือเปล่าแม่ดอก
แก้วฉันเนี่ยเป็นคนไม่มีอะไรเลยนะไม่มี
เงินไม่มีบ้านใหญ่นะไม่มีรถไม่มีที่ดิน
ใหญ่ๆนะฉันก็ไม่ได้ทำงานไม่มีตำแหน่งหน้า
ที่การงานอืนะแต่ดอกแก้วว่ายังไงค่ะดอก
แก้วก็บอกว่าไม่ผิดหรอกถ้าท่านคือขนุนนะ
เพราะข้าเนี่ยรู้สึกประทับใจในสิ่งที่
ท่านเนี่ยได้ช่วยเหลือชาวบ้านนะเศรษฐีทอง
คำก็พูดเหมือนกันนะแม้นเจ้าจะเป็นขนุนที่
ต่ำต้อยที่คนดูถูกเจ้าแต่การกระทำของเจ้า
เนี่ยเอ่อได้ได้ให้เราเห็นแล้วคนอื่นๆ
เห็นแล้วว่าการกระทำของเจ้าเนี่ยมันสูง
มันไม่ต่ำนะฮะเจ้าเนี่ยเอ่อไม่เลือกที่จะ
ไม่เลือกที่จะหรือเมินเฉยกับเรื่องเดือด
ร้อนของของชาวบ้านข้าเนี่ยรู้สึกขอบคุณ
เจ้ามากนะคะแล้วก็รู้สึกว่าเจ้าเนี่ย
เหมาะที่จะเป็นผู้นำหมู่บ้านแห่งนี้แล้ว
ก็เมื่อลูกสาวเราเนี่ยเลือกเจ้าด้วยเจ้า
ก็เหมาะที่จะเป็นลูกเขยค่ะเช่นเดียวกันอ
ว่าแล้วเศรษฐีทองคำก็ประกาศเลยค่ะประกาศ
ให้ขนุนเนี่ยเป็นลูกเขยและก็เป็นเจ้ามือ
เมืองค่ะโอเป็นหัวหน้าหมู่บ้านทองดีเลย
โอ้เพราะว่าเจอลูกเขยที่ดีแล้วเนาะก็เลย
ตัดสินใจให้ลูกเขยเนี่ยดูแลหมู่บ้านแล้ว
ก็แต่งงานกับลูกสาวนะแล้วก็ดูแลทรัพย์สิน
ของนะท่านเศรษฐีทองคำอืโอเห็นมั้ยคะคุณ
ค่าของคนเนี่ยไม่ได้อยู่ที่มีเงินมากนะคะ
คุณค่าของคนไม่ได้อยู่ที่เรียนเรียนจบสูง
คุณค่าของคนเนี่ยจะดูดีหรือไม่ดีเนี่ย
อยู่ที่การกระทำของตัวเองนะคุณค่าในที่
นี้ก็คือประโยชน์เนาะทำประโยชน์ให้กับคน
อื่นหรือว่ามีค่าในตัวเองไม่ใช่เป็นค่า
ที่เปลี่ยนเป็นเงินแต่มันเป็นความดีความ
มีน้ำใจหลายๆอย่างเนาะก็เป็นคุณค่านะใช่
เพราะเค้าเนี่ยคิดถึงเรื่องของคนอื่นมา
เป็นที่ 1 เรื่องของตัวเองลองลงมาเป็นที่
2 เห็นมยเพราะฉะนั้นเคเหมาะแล้วค่ะที่จะ
เป็นผู้นำหมู่บ้านนี้
อก็วันนี้เนี่ยเราก็หมดเวลาที่เอาเรื่อง
ของขนุนเนี่ยมาพูดคุยเป็นนิทานที่สอนใจ
ที่คนไทยบอกว่าไว้สอนเด็กๆให้เด็กๆเนี่ย
รู้ว่าตัวเองจะไม่มีเงินยากจนไม่มีความ
รู้แต่ถ้าตัวเองเนี่ยทำประโยชน์ให้กับคน
อื่นมากมายคุคุณก็มีคุณค่านะฮะนะมีแต่คน
รักคนพูดถึงมันทำให้คุณเนี่ยสูงขึ้นอนะเ
เรียกว่าคุณค่าของคนเนี่ยไม่ใช่อยู่ที่
เราเป็นคนยกตัวเองแต่เป็นคนอื่นที่มอง
เห็นแล้วก็ก็ให้คุณค่ากับเราเนาะยกย่อง
เราอย่างเงี้ค่ะนะก็คือไม่ด้อยค่าตัวเอง
ไม่คิดว่าตัวเองเนี่ยไม่ดีอย่างงั้นไม่ดี
อย่างงี้อันนี้บูลี่ตัวเองยิ่งไม่ดีใหญ่
เลยเนาเอใช่ค่ะเนาะก็วันนี้ก็ดีค่ะได้ฟัง
นิทานนักเรียนฟังทันมยก็ถ้าฟังทันก็ไม่
ทันก็กลับมาฟังใหม่เนาะเออป่ะวันนี้ค่ะก็
หมดเวลาแล้วแล้วเราก็ขอลาทุกคนไปก่อนค่ะ
ใครคิดเห็นยังไงก็สวัสดีคอมเมนต์มานะคะ
สวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบายบ๊ายบายค่ะ